do you want to explain what christmas in
japan is like yeah so essentially
by kfc yeah basically yeah yeah
christmas in japan is sponsored by kfc
basically it's like
kfc is the go-to place how did that
start
how did that start okay it's because i
did a video on this a few years ago but
basically
the theory is that colonel sanders right
looks like santa that's the theory
because think about it right think about
it christmas colors what are the
christmas colors red
yeah right yeah yeah what does colonel
sanders dressed up in red
right yeah that's a white suit i thought
yeah but the kfc color has red
and then colonel sanders is an old guy
with a white beard
kind of looks like santa right and i bet
if you trace that back it's like the
most
five-head kfc employee like working
marketing team
it's basically it it's it's it's a it
was a marketing ploy by kfc to be oh it
was
yeah yeah like basically yeah basically
like they were like well uh you know the
christmas dinner overseas in in
in the west is uh they have chicken yeah
they've roast chicken
fried chicken is kind of the same thing
right it's like you know it's still
chicken
yeah what why don't we try this let's
try one christmas that's pretty funny
we're gonna try and sell this and it
just [ __ ] exploded because
you can't get a roast chicken in japan
and also other than kfc
out of outside of some kombini's i saw
this there'd be a an employee dressed in
a santa outfit
yeah with a a fried chicken like yeah
selling
fried chicken yeah yeah yeah sell fried
chicken they sell like cakes
looking at an asian man dressed in a
santa costume sell me fried chicken
in the name of christmas but it's also
weird as well because like
normally like everywhere else in the
west right christmas is like a family
thing right you gather like mom dad
yeah but in japan it's like a beta
valentine's day yeah it's a reality
it's it's like you go on dates yeah you
go you you go to the prom that's
that's that's uh christmas here but that
but that part i
understand because literally a week
later is uh new year's eve right and new
year's eve is like a super like buddhist
family thing in japan
yeah so it makes sense that the opposite
of what it is in western yeah
it's like in western cultures like oh
new year's eve
yeah let's go forward see you next year
parents yeah so
i don't know i just i personally have i
i mean well
this year i plan to go up uh north to go
see uh chris
um and uh we're gonna we're gonna go to
natsuki's place and have kfc
for christmas yeah that's the plan
that's the plan and i'm like
man first time ever i've been living
here five years first year i'm gonna
have the true japanese christmas
experience of eating kfc
i'll let you boys know how depressing it
actually is
but uh having because it's not like i i
remember before coming to japan
i'd heard so many rumors about japanese
kfc being like
the best kfc in the world you you ain't
tried kfc
until you had japanese kfc and then i
came here and then i ate it
and then it was just kfc yeah genuinely
think the uk one was better even
i thought the uk we had a better menu it
is the most meat kfc i've ever had
yeah man i love the burgers the chicken
sandwiches that you get in kfc they're
[ __ ] amazing oh yeah in the uk
they're so good as well honestly i don't
know what it is about uk or kfc's it's
good
i mean i i feel though you guys have
kind of perfected like fast food chicken
with nando's right
i mean that's like south african though
yeah right but we just
i think every single fast food chain in
the uk has like fried chicken
options like but as a not on its own
right like mcdonald's
i think some of the most popular stuff
they sell in the uk is like just like a
chicken celery chicken chicken select
and also like the wrap chicken
yeah okay that's [ __ ] me that's the
best thing i get yeah that stuff is good
and every like every like dirty kebab
still has like the fried chicken option
as well
so there's just fried chicken everywhere
but like yeah
i don't know like because yeah british
is the best kfc japan is like somewhere
in the middle
and then america's america is just like
do i want to feel like [ __ ]
yeah kfc it is yeah i i don't know why
like american kfc just stopped trying
because it's not like america doesn't
have bad
fried chicken options it's just one of
their like some of their biggest chains
are just the worst in america
and i don't understand why i was drunk
one time someone gave me a kfc chicken
in america yeah and even drunk me was
like this is vile
and you know it's bad if i drunk me is
like this is too much i draw the line
the amount of grease that's on this
thing yeah like the skin wasn't crispy
it was
moist from all the grease it had and i'm
like that's vile sorry we somehow
turned this all around to bashing
america i love america i do i just
what's going on there
you can do chicken correctly case in
point chick-fil-a yeah chick-fil-a
but like that's why i don't understand
why anyone in america would eat kfc when
there's like
chick-fil-a or popeyes was good reviews
on google maps
or for like kfc it's always like two
stars and i'm like who's willingly going
in here
stop giving them [ __ ] customers just
stop yeah
it's sunday right and chick-fil-a is
closed yeah that's true
i mean not not all parts of america have
chick-fil-a apparently
uh yeah i know they don't do that east
coast doesn't have chick-fil-a or
something i don't know
there's like different chains like
different areas as well i know
but what i know is kfc's the worst fried
chicken yeah